vous avez tous lu le roman de melville
vous avez dû voir le célèbre film moby
dick
vous savez c'est l'histoire du grand
cachalot qui arracha la jambe du
capitaine achats c'est un roman
magnifique
quand je pense que les cachalots ont
failli disparaître de notre planète
à deux reprises la première fois c'était
à la fin du 19ème début xxème siècle il
été pêchés pour leur huile qu'on appelle
le sperme à city à l'époque les gens
s'éclairer et se réchauffer avec ce
produit naturel et ce qui est paradoxal
c'est qu'ils doivent leur salut à
l'arrivée du pétrole
mais la pire époque pour eux a duré de
la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
jusqu'au début des années 60
beaucoup de pays avait relancé la chasse
parce que le peuple parce que le sperme
as et y servait à la fabrication de la
nitroglycérine et de lubrifiants pour
les rouages mécanique
ici le roman de melville était vrai et
si je vous disais que j'ai peut-être
rencontrer l'arrière arrière
petite-fille de moby dick
en tout cas ce soir je vais vous
présenter ces géants des mers les
cachalots de l'île maurice pour moi tout
a commencé en 2010 lorsque je tourne un
documentaire sur la plongée sous marine
comme mon ami hugues vitry en jour
naturaliste mauricien m'a permis de
plonger pour la première fois avec les
cachalots
il me tient à coeur ce soir de vous
faire partager cette expérience
avez vous envie de plonger dans un
espace-temps unique qui montre que ces
animaux sont hors du commun
oui alors c'est parti
je m'en souviendrai toujours
j'étais tout seul dans le grand bleu sur
un fond de 1500 m en dessous des à 30
mètres j'aperçois une masse somme qui
grossit assez rapidement il mesuré ou
plutôt elle mesure et 10 m pour 15
tonnes
car c'était une femelle elle s'est
retournée
elle m'a regardé avec scepticisme les sa
grande gueule elle avait l'air à la fois
curieuse et intrigué je me concentrais
sur mon écran parce que je voulais
absolument pas rater ce premier plan
finalement à la comptine son chemin
comme si rien ne s'était passé
ouf je me suis dit moby dick n'est pas
aussi agressif que dans le roman
avez vous déjà plongé avec un sous marin
qui déboule devant vous non moi non plus
pourtant c'est vraiment l'impression que
j'ai eue
lorsque j'ai filmé mon premier mal
depuis 2010 chaque année je retourne à
l'humoriste
et chaque année je vois la famille
s'agrandir et évoluer avec françois
sarano océanographe
nous avons identifié à ce jour 100
individus 23 mal
soixante deux femelles et 15 juges
binnie ils ont tous un prénom et une
carte d'identité
pourquoi sont ils résident maurice
comment vit-il et que font-ils qu'en
fait ils vivent un peu comme nous mais
un stade supérieur
ils ont choisi ce territoire parce que
la nourriture est suffisamment abondante
pour nourrir tout le monde
ils ne mangent pas à leur faim censure
consommer ni stoker inutile heures
et ça tombe bien ici il ya un super
garde-manger rempli de calamars donc le
fameux calamars chez les mâles qui ont
atteint une maturité partent à la
découverte des océans seuls les adultes
peuvent descendre à 1500 m les balises
que nous avons posées ont montré qu un
cachalot est descendu à 1200 mètres
durant 52 minutes il est remonté à la
vitesse de 70 mètres minute
c'est incroyable quand je pense que le
plongeur théo marc rost moss qui détient
actuellement le record du monde de
plongée en caisson a mis 18 jours pour
décembre à moins 700 à m oui et il a dû
patienter encore 24 23 jours avant de
regagner la surface
son immersion a duré au total 31 jours
oui un mois les cachalots défie toutes
les lois physiques hyperbare comment
fonctionne le clan comme chez les
éléphants
c'est la matriarche qui s'occupe des
jeunes vous vous souvenez le premier
cachalot que j'avais filmé en 2010
labrosse femelles avec la gueule tordu
c'est la matriarche depuis 2014 nous
l'avons identifié sous le nom de irène
gueule tordu chaque année elle me
reconnaît et viennent me voir
écoutez bien le son qu'elle est mais
elle est empreinte de mystère
commun
en france on est tellement puissants
qu'ils me transperce à la cage
thoracique
ils se déplacent par eco localisation
ils s'en servent aussi aux détecter et
attraper les calamars dans le north j là
j'ai au dessus de ma tête vingtaine de
tendresse regardez son agilité et la
précision de ses mouvements
irène ne m'a jamais touchée pour
communiquer entre eux il utilise des
sons qu'on appelle des coda ce sont des
clics et se passer dans une plage de
fréquence à maurice il utilise hui coda
contre 5 à la dominique
oui les cachalots ont un dialecte
différents selon la zone géographique où
il se trouve
peut-être que ceux de maurice qui
parle-t-il une sorte de créole
les scientifiques travaillent dessus
ils sont aussi un peu comme nous lui
communique avec le geste et la parole
et quand ils veulent repousser un intrus
il ne lésine pas sur les moyens
mais revenait rengel tordu le mardi 23
février de cette année elles viennent me
voir pour me montrer qu'elle est
enceinte jusqu'aux yeux le mercredi vers
l'océan et vide personne et je me dis ah
là là je suis sûr qu'elle va mettre bas
aujourd'hui
bingo irène accouche de la petite lana
un beau bébé de 3 mètres pour 250 kg et
le lendemain elle vient me présenter son
nouveau né qui a encore le cordon
ombilical accroché là vous êtes avec
lucie et la petite darren qui à
seulement trois semaines
c'est la première fois qu'elle motorisés
avait filmé le de ces prêts je vous
laisse admirer cette séquence tendresse
les femelles font un bébé tous les cinq
à six ans l'allaitement dure deux ans et
ce qui est remarquable c'est que nous
avons découvert grâce aux vidéos qu'un
bébé pouvait été sur plusieurs nounou
pendant que sa maman par chasser dans
les abysses où va se reposer
c'est un peu pareil chez les éléphants
et je vais vous donner un scoop
cette année j'ai filmé la petite lana
qui t'était sa nounou yukimi mais yukimi
n'a jamais eu de bb auparavant
en tout cas pas depuis les dix dernières
années mais alors d'où vient ce sont les
avants nous pensions que le temps de la
gestation était de 2 ans car les gros
mal venait uniquement pour s'accoupler
toujours à la même période
les dernières vidéos ont montré que les
mâles viennent pratiquement toute
l'année il qu'ils aient un comportement
structurale et sociale avec le clan je
vous présente elliott
il ya cinq ans il est très joueur et
curieux lui aussi quand ils me reconnaît
il me scan et il vient même jusqu'au
contact
je suis rentré en france deux jours
après avoir tourné cette séquence du
guitry me téléphone pour me dire qu'il
s'est passé quelque chose
d'extraordinaire avec elliott
au début ils ne comprenaient pas ce qui
se passait ils étaient venus avec la
gueule ouverte
elliott avait l'air bizarre et août
s'est approché et il a remarqué qu'il
avait un hameçon planté dans la gueule
bugle à rassurer en le caressant puis il
a envoyé ses mains pour décrocher
l'hameçon sans lui faire de mal
enfin ils se sont fait un gros câlin et
tout s'est bien terminé
quand je n'étais pas là quand cette
scène s'est déroulée
vous allez me dire mais qui a tourné ces
images vous le savez c'est moi mais
comment est-ce que tourner ces images si
je n'étais pas là et bien voilà quand il
m'a appelé il m'a dit rené ne t'inquiète
pas je regarde l'hameçon et l'année
prochaine avec elliott
quand tu reviendras nous referons la
même séquence
je me suis dit mais oui c'est ça même
pas en rêve et durant tout ce temps je
ne pensais qu'à ça
mais sans trop y croire l'année suivante
je suis retourné à maurice et elliot et
hu ont rejoué exactement la même
séquence
oui vous venez de voir une
reconstitution parfaite
je vous rappelle t-il yacht est un
animal complètement sauvage
j'ai tourné en live je pense que même
gérard depardieu à vous le connaissez je
pense que même jarre depardieu n'aurait
jamais pu rejouer une séquence est là
après 100 répétition
quand je suis sortie de lure j'avais les
larmes dans le masque ces animaux sont
l'aude et sont dotés d'une intelligence
exceptionnelle et d'une tendresse que
personne ne peut imaginer tant que vous
n'êtes pas partager ces moments
inoubliables avec eux ils m'ont
accueilli dans leur famille ils m'ont
permis de filmer des tranches de leur
vie si intime que personne n'avait pu
voir jusqu'à présent jamais je ne les
abandonnerai il y a des gens qui se
prennent d'affection pour des chiens des
chats des chevaux moi j rengel tordu
elliott darren et les autres voilà nous
allons commencer à refaire surface et
après avoir vu ces images
j'espère que vous porterez un autre
regard sur ces géant débonnaire
comment peut-on faire du mal à ces
mammifères marins
si sensible je vous rappelle qu'ils ont
failli disparaître de notre planète à
deux reprises et ils ont été sauvés car
nous nous sommes mobilisés
et en créant des espaces protégés et ça
a marché parce que les cachalots sont
sédentaires par contre il n'en est pas
de même pour les baleines qui chaque
année doivent parcourir des milliers de
kilomètres pour aller se nourrir dans
l'épaule et maître ben dans les eaux
chaudes
le trajet est long très long
beaucoup d'entre elles n'arriveront pas
jusqu'au bout du voyage parce qu'elles
seront pêchés et tuée par les baleiniers
d'autres pêcheurs aussi n'hésitent pas à
massacrer les dauphins et les
globicéphales quelle est votre part de
responsabilités la mienne elle est très
claire
et si j'ai partagé ce soir ces images
avec vous c'est parce qu'il est encore
temps de ramener la paix dans les océans
et de laisser vivre ses habitants en
paix et en harmonie
je compte sur vous merci
[Applaudissements]